he is the winningest coach in Stanford
school history David Shaw how are you
coach I'm great rich how you doing I'm
doing fine
so what what what where are you right
now in your preparations for the year
college football right around the corner
here where are you you know we're we're
five practices in six practice today
actually we had a day off yesterday they
offer practice n-c-double-a mandated so
we went and saw our good old friend mike
Mayock down at Raiders camp which was
good got the staff out there to go see
go see Mike and spend some time with him
and they look good I think they're on
the on the bounce back from from a tough
year but love their draft picks and I
think Mike's done a great job there did
you see Mike's hot-air-balloon in the
background did you see I did not see his
hot-air balloon
he may have deflated it for the day you
know he's big-time out there now David
you know Mike as well as anybody and
we've worked with him and we've been
there we've done that okay what if you
had ever pulled him aside because he
respects you immensely I mean I'm not
saying that he doesn't respect me but he
knows I'd like to just yank his chain
but if you pulled it like seven years
ago and you'd say to him hey Mike one
day you're gonna be a general manager in
the NFL and you are gonna put a lot of
eggs in the basket of a very talented
wide receiver who you know can do some
strange things but here is what's gonna
happen he's gonna arrive to your first
training camp in a hot air balloon with
frostbitten feet from a cryo chamber
that he didn't put the proper booties on
and you're not going to be able to
practice him what do you think he would
have said David yeah back in the day he
probably would have had a bit of a
problem with this he's you know he's a
defensive backs has got something
against those receivers anyway right he
gets over it when he's evaluating but
he's also a big Belichick guy and I
think he would have a very similar
reaction to what Belichick would
probably react it's crazy how life works
it really is it's you know but how sense
of you know whatever you want to share
the sense of what what it does look at
like a traitor's practice when you say
that they look good I mean what from
your evaluation I did you see about this
team you know it was obvious what they
tried to do they upgraded speed
the running back from Alabama looks
outstanding you know the safety they
took in my first round flying around
being physical getting a lot of
publicity for pretty people etcetera but
right you know that's when they drafted
him for that's what he's paid to do and
hopefully he does with the pads on that
weapon without the pads but Faro the
long athletic pass rusher brought in
some other free agents and just on the
hoof
seeing them last year they look like a
bigger Longer offensive team in
particular up from the offensive line
they look like monsters but Jacob is big
yeah Jacobs was that kid we talked about
first night of the draft wouldn't that's
how Mike and the Raiders finished up
there their first night of three
first-round picks you just mentioned all
three of them in Farrell Abram but
Jacobs does he he looks like an NFL
ready to roll dynamic back to you he
does he does is his quickness in and out
of the hole it's impressed we got a
chance to watch them against the Rams
scrimmage against the Rams and to see
him change direction and move and
accelerate and I know Jon Gruden loves
to run a football and use the
play-action pass so that's going to be a
big part of their game with a big
physical offensive line it could be
exciting in the Raider world this year
David Shaw Stanford head coach before we
get to your team let's just keep your
draft analyst hat on if you don't mind
from from our our first night together
Daniel Jones we're gonna get out there
tonight it looks like and see what he
looks like for the Giants against the
Jets what should we be seeing from him
in a preseason game in any sort of
action that would give us an indication
that the the very negative reviews of
the Giants drafting him where they did
what might be off that he can do what
their Giants are hoping him to do what
you'd love to see and I'm an old West
Coast guy you love to see efficiency you
love to see a guy go out there get the
ball out of his hands he's well coach
coming out coming out of college but she
loves to make quick decisions get the
ball out of his hands move the team he
loves him take him on a scoring try but
they don't have to score you want to see
that vision of got the guy playing
quarterback right not rattled by the
rush getting the ball out of his hands
push up in the pocket because he's a
good athlete maybe scram before first
down
you just love to see some real positive
plays I mean this is this is going to be
something he's never done before with a
group going after him that he's never
faced before but at the same time he's
got better talent around that he's never
had before so you just want to see
something positive come out of it he
shouldn't look like Johnny Unitas on day
one but he should look like an efficient
quarterback and for me honestly he's got
this talent he's got the tools most
people thought gosh if he comes back
he's gonna be that much better
comes back to school but he's in the NFL
now he's got the tools you just love to
see some efficiency and really good
efficient quarterback play and what are
you expecting out of Mauri in Kingsbury
they I'm assuming they they're not gonna
give away the store here that they want
to make sure that when Murray comes out
of the box against the Lions that that
Matt Patricia has zero tape is that much
zero tape to work with how do you think
that's gonna work tonight with Lori in
Kingsbury and the rest of the preseason
you know I don't know cliff very well
we've interacted a couple of times he
gives me the sense that I don't think he
cares you know I don't think he cares
I think hey we're gonna go out there
running around the yard I want to get
this coat quarterback comfortable we're
going to get the guys around and move in
we'll put some film out there and we'll
do some some stuff we're going to do
during the year maybe do some stuff that
maybe we're not going to do during the
year but I think their main focus is
that got a franchise quarterback they
want to put him out there for his
limited role they want the guy to get a
first taste of the NFL and feel good
about getting the ball out of his hands
I think that's the main priority and
then in terms of Haskins tonight they're
you know Donald PennDOT got signed by
Washington with Trent Williams sitting
out they tried Eric flowers at the
position you got a rookie running back
with an offensive line that might be in
flux what do you think we're expecting
to see out of him for the Redskins
tonight you know Haskins I thought was
was probably the the top prototypical
NFL quarterback in the draft and I think
his footwork is good I think he's gonna
he's got a lot to learn I would think
three times during the course that game
you're gonna see the howitzer
all right you're gonna see why he got
drafted so high why so many people were
really enamored with him you know who
knows how he's going to play you know
hopefully he plays well and moves the
team but a couple times that came he's
got to unleash that arm and it's
impressive he'll be whoop it's one of
the stronger arms in the NFL he's in
that upper echelon and I think you're
gonna see it and then in terms of what
we're seeing David Shaw Stanford head
coach here Christian McCaffrey appears
to be ready to just absolutely explode
and be a potential thousand thousand guy
I mean Norv Turner and him when when cam
looked healthy last year
he just he was ready to go I'm wondering
what your sense of it is now it's year
three we can clearly see that this kid
can run between tackles this is no joke
here whatwhat do you think David Scholl
well first I clear my toes here for a
second I told you so special his body
and don't Freda left after his junior
year so his body is still maturing so
he's gotten bigger he is stronger he is
215 pounds and he's just as fast just as
quick he'd probably stay faster and
quicker this kids on a mission I would
just keep the record book open and just
kind of glance it a couple of things
will he be the next I was only two or
three thousand thousand-yard guys and
history of the league keep your eye on
that there's also an NFL record that was
helped by another Stanford man Glyn
Milburn most total yards most
all-purpose yards in a game I'd watch
out for that one also this kid is on a
mission he is quick he's explosive he's
worked his tail off this offseason and
North Turner knows how to use a guy like
him he's with LaDainian Tomlinson so
don't be surprised if this is last year
was a breakout year this might be a
record year for the kid do you need a
lozenge we had we had many conversations
about this guy coming out and and this
is anybody who saw him lives is not
surprised that this is happening this is
just who this young man is and it's only
gonna get better any concern about luck
in any of your conversations you've had
with him
now we got a lower leg we now I got his
little but lower than the waist it
situation for him coming in to the
season no no it's it's a twinge I think
he and everybody's being overly cautious
they know what he's like when he when
he's 100% that's the goal is to get him
hundred percent for Game one and he
feels great and the rest of his body the
99 percent of his body feels great he's
just got to get past this this lower
calf deal and once he's there he has no
concern about it it's just getting ready
for week 1 a couple more minutes left
with David Shaw of Stanford Boyd is your
team come out of the box Northwestern at
use USC at UCF versus Oregon that is
just a real tough first four weeks and
then you know obviously you're you've
got kids that need to get up to speed
and begin to figure out how to play with
one another what is the challenge for
you here coach well the first challenge
northwestern a first pass the cereals
done out saying job in Northwest and
he's built that program from where it
was when he first got there over this
past decade he's really built a strong
program made it way it's made their way
to the Big Ten championship game last
year played Ohio State extremely tough
this battle for us got a start on the
offensive side with the offensive line
up front on their front seven they are
long their physical they're relentless
and we're going to match their intensity
with a lot of guys are going to be a
little experienced they're going to gain
experience very quickly against a very
good defensive front defensively
hey we got to stop the run we got to be
physical up front we got some really
good corners on the back end hopefully
we can and we can slow down the passing
game as well but right off the bat it's
going to be a big big showdown you know
I just this is what I see this and I'm
like this is a this is a way to start a
season image in terms of tough schedule
then you see other other programs they
just don't do it
is there any sort of sort of movement to
try and force teams to scheduled teams
that you think are worthy of the school
and and the program David it just
doesn't seem very fair to me it's not
uniform
it is not even close and I've told many
people all the way up to through all the
n-c-double-a through the commissioners
I've talked to right I was schooled as
an NSL guy and nine years in the NFL
when I was at the Raiders if the Broncos
played an easier schedule than us I'd be
excited be upset right they have an
easier path to the playoffs so the West
was kind of going on a college football
right now and at some point it's going
to take an organizational decision to
push conferences into alignment to say
we're all going towards a playoff let's
have a similar path towards the playoff
either we're all going to play nine
conference games or we're all going to
play eight we're all going to play a one
double a team or we're not maybe we'll
play one but let's have the same exact
rules so that everyone has the same path
towards a championship in their own
conference and an opportunity to get to
the playoff so we're nowhere close to
that right now but that's where a lot of
us are trying to urge everybody to go in
that direction before I let you go coach
you just mentioned your years in the NFL
ed Reed just got into the Hall of Fame
yeah I'm sure you've spent some time in
Baltimore when he was bawling out do you
have a good at read story anything that
just jumps off the top yes I could do an
entire show with four years with Ed Reed
but the thing with IDI that a lot of
people don't understand you see Ed he's
a little over 510 he's but right about
200 pounds not the biggest guy this guy
could change the game
in less than five seconds right he's one
of two guys I ever saw in the NFL he and
Troy Polamalu that could blitz from 12
to 14 yards away from the line of
scrimmage at the snap and hit the
quarterback at the top of this drop
speed and explosion but my favorite
Eddie Reid moment were playing at the
Jets at the two-minute drill the Jets
are driving down he intercepts the ball
in the end zone
and Ray Lewis tries to tell him to stay
in the end zone he fakes out a Ray Lewis
and takes it all the way down the field
and it's just one of those things you
just don't stop ed Reed you follow ed
Reed he's a special person he's a
special football player and I was
excited he didn't get inducted me too so
you're saying that not
even Ray Lewis could stop a train is
what you're saying yeah what I'm saying
is those two guys on the same team some
games it just wasn't fair I bet not and
pull them all is of eligible next year
so I'm assuming he should go into in
that regard I hope so hey David I love
our chats miss chatting with you I hope
to chat with you down the line okay
thanks for the call
thanks for it you got it you got that
stay bad Shaw Stanford head coach at
coach David Shaw on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app